pourquoi un agriculteur achèterait-il
une terre loin de chez lui pour ne
jamais la cultiver ce qui préfère d'une
superficie exploitable en fait c'est à
cause d'un règlement adopté au début des
années 2000 pour protéger
l'environnement un règlement qui a
aujourd'hui des effets pervers dans le
monde agricole
[Musique]
ces petites épinettes ont causé toute
une commotion lors de leur plantation en
mai dernier sur une terre agricole de
Sainte-Justine dans la région de
chaudière à Palace
une agricultrice de la région qui a tiré
la sonnette d'alarme elle a publié ses
photos accompagnée d'un message sur les
réseaux sociaux
puis au printemps j'ai décidé d'aller
voir ça s'est donné une journée que les
gens du groupement forestier est en
train de planter c'était désolé de voir
une grande prairie de 40 ans que se
faire détruire par des petites épinettes
qu'on pourra plus on pourra plus jamais
enlever pour faire de la terre
cultivable
pour comprendre pourquoi la Terre de
Sainte Justine ne pourra plus jamais
être cultivée il faut faire un saut dans
le temps au milieu des années 90
l'industrie portine québécoise est en
pleine expansion les éleveurs répandent
beaucoup de fumier dans les champs ce
lisier finit par polluer les cours d'eau
les opposants d'expansion des mégas
porcheries au Québec ont trouvé une
nouvelle tribune ils étaient venus de
plusieurs régions du Québec des groupes
de citoyens des environnementsalistes
pour dire qu'ils ont perdu confiance
dans le ministère de l'Environnement en
ce qui concerne le dossier des
porcheries et de la pollution des cours
d'eau
[Musique]
en 2002
lisant
La Conte de nouvelles porcheries les
Québécois c'est ça qu'ils disent il y a
actuellement avec cette production qui a
connu une expansion importante dans
certaines régions du Québec des
problématiques environnementales
importantes en ce qui concerne ces
hommes qui sont actuellement surplus
pour le part nous disons aucune nouvelle
porcherie
on défend en porcherie un exploitation
dépendre plus de lisiers que ce que la
terre est capable d'en absorber ça veut
dire que la quantité de phosphore un des
éléments nutritifs contenus dans le
lisier et qui peut nuire au cours d'eau
doit être calculé pour se conformer à la
loi certains agriculteurs déboisent
davantage de terre pour équilibrer leur
bilan phosphore lors de l'épandage de
fumier devant le déboisement excessif
pratiqué par certains le ministère de
l'Environnement impose un moratoire il
interdit à tous les agriculteurs pas
uniquement les éleveurs de porc
d'agrandir leur superficie en culture
dans certaines municipalités
celle située dans des bassins versants
dégradés les zones géographiques
traversées par des cours d'eau pollués
mais il y a une exception un producteur
peut agrandir une parcelle des gens en
culture à condition de compenser par
l'achat d'une autre terre qui elle ne
pourra plus jamais être cultivé
à ce moment-là il peut soit la laisser à
l'abandon donc en fiche la reboiser ou y
faire la culture de petits fruits
essentiellement sur cette personne on
pourra jamais recultiver ça non pour
l'objectif en fait c'est de ne pas
augmenter la pression du monde agricole
sur des bassins versants qui sont
dégradés et donc de limiter l'impact que
l'agriculture peut avoir sur la qualité
des cours d'eau dans ces secteurs-là
ce mécanisme prévu par la loi s'appelle
un déplacement de parcelle c'est ce qui
s'est produit à Sainte Justine la Terre
a été achetée et reboisée par un
agriculteur de Saint Joseph de Beauce à
55 km de là dans une autre
je pense que le producteur de Saint
Joseph doit pas être tellement fier
d'aller dire je t'allais enlever 40
heures de terrain cultivables dans une
autre région il fait pour ses besoins il
fait parce que c'est qu'il peut le faire
légalement
pour tes réglementaires et
il raconte toutes les normes
mais dans certaines que
ils doivent être très très fiers de
faire sur mon plus si la terre de Sainte
Justine a été condamnée c'est pour que
le producteur de la bosse puis
s'agrandir la superficie de ces cultures
chez lui le producteur en question a
refusé nous accorder une entrevue à la
caméra nous reproduisons ici les propos
qu'il nous a tenu lorsque nous l'avons
joint au téléphone depuis que la dame a
écrit ça sur les réseaux sociaux même si
je suis en loi je me fais agacer avec ça
quand je vais au restaurant La Terre
elle était avant pour tout le monde je
ne l'ai pas volé à personne
[Musique]
dans la MRC des Etchemins là où se
trouve la terre de Sainte-Justine
Fortier se désole
sont rares dans la région qui est boisé
à 88 %
[Musique]
ça va être comme à côté là-bas un petit
peu de plantations
[Musique]
qu'on a aujourd'hui les Banneux les
piles parce que moi je suis la quatrième
génération aussi depuis 1914 que c'est
la forme des fortiers puis
de ce que je suis comme l'histoire de
faire de la bâtie vers des chevaux
c'était l'ouvrage voir les gens comme on
voit ici là tu as tout en forêt avant
toutes les affaires
[Rires]
on recule avec nos ancêtres ils ont eu
de l'insubent ensemble de la société
pour le soir et faire du drainage d'une
image tu la mets potable les rochers des
fois et qui ont tout eu ça de la société
puis après ça revient là-bas on gaspille
ce terrain-là culture c'est une
aberration
[Musique]
à titre de président de la fédération de
l'UPR de la chaudière à Palace James
Allen déplore que la loi est permit le
déplacement de parcelles entre région et
éloignées des producteurs de
Saint-Hyacinthe ont déjà acheté des
terres aussi loin qu'en habitibi pour
agrandir leur superficie en Montérégie
c'est des régions un petit peu plus
peut-être pas mais l'agriculture est un
petit peu plus dynamique qui vont
acheter ou ce que l'agriculture
c'est c'est le capitalisme extrême dans
ce temps là
si je veux acheter une terre à 1000
pièces là dans un autre municipalité que
je viens avec la laisse sans friche ou
peu importe ce qui arrive là-bas puis
genre des boises moins que je prenne
terre à 1000 pièces là que je viens
transvider à 10000 pièces là
[Musique]
le cannibalisme qui se fait à cause du
ministère de l'Environnement parce que
l'agriculture c'est cannibalisme entre
elles à cause du moratoire qu'est-ce que
vous voulez dire
une région agricole est en train de
manger un autre région agricole moi
c'est pas rien d'autre que du
cannibalisme moi quand j'ai fait un post
au mois de mai je pense que j'ai eu 50
appels dans la semaine que suivi des
gens de partout que je ne connais pas
partout ailleurs où est-ce qu'il y avait
le même genre de de situation les gens
se sont dit bon écoutons on n'est pas
tout seul et que ça arrive de se faire
voler une terre voler de se faire
enlever du terrain agricole
pour permettre à d'autres de se déboîter
ailleurs
dans chaudière Appalache on se creuse
les méninges la plantation d'épinettes à
Sainte-Justine qui a été financée par
des données publiques inspire une
solution à James Harlem
[Rires]
je pose la faucheuse les plats ont été
plantés au mois de main là
on a un an ou deux
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra faire
on peut peut-être imaginer de créer une
banque de fond de terre qui est pas
nécessairement
intéressante à cultiver et puis qui
pourrait servir à rebroiser dans le
cadre des échanges comme ça comment ça
peut gérer je sais pas
protéger nos terres
protéger le terrain agricole cultivable
c'est précieux on veut un autonomie
alimentaire dans notre province
ça prend de la terre pour la faire
sur toi des maisons
[Musique]
acheter des terres loin de sa ferme avec
l'engagement de ne jamais les cultiver
tout ça pour équilibrer son bilan
environnemental c'est une pratique qui
est de plus en plus décrié à tel point
que certains élus réclament aujourd'hui
au gouvernement que des terres
condamnées plus à nouveau être cultivés
[Musique]
la MRC des Appalaches dans la région de
thetfelmans est loin d'être un paradis
pour l'agriculture c'est des terres qui
sont pas nécessairement très faciles ces
détails un peu à rire de roche qu'on
appelle ici là pratiquement si on n'est
pas dans les meilleurs têtes du Québec
donc dans paire d'une comme ça ben tu
sais ça fait ça fait pas mal au cœur
la terre perdue la voici
100 ancre à l'entrée d'Adstock dans le
secteur sacré-cœur de Marie
jusqu'à tout récemment cette terre était
cultivable mais elle a été vendue dans
le cadre du mécanisme de déplacement de
parcelles
ce qu'on demande au ministère de
l'Environnement c'est de revoir
laboratoire
dans un premier temps puis aux enfants
au ministère de l'Agriculture on demande
une disposition spéciale de retrouver le
droit de production de cette terre-là
afin qu'on puisse y produire et cultiver
comme comme c'était possible avant
[Musique]
d'autant plus problématique que la
municipalité essaie d'attirer de jeunes
agriculteurs dans la région
[Musique]
à la disposition de ceux qui attendent
de pouvoir mettre la main sur une terre
[Musique]
Marjorie Lehoux est l'une d'elles elle
cultive des légumes biologiques et des
fleurs comestibles
la jeune femme aurait bien voulu acheter
la fameuse terre de saint-acre les gens
du village tient sacré-cœur m'avaient
dit que il y avait une terre avant au
400 du village donc moi je suis allée
colise directement chez le médecin en
question pour voir à fait si la terre
était réellement à vendre j'avais déjà
les finances pour acheter le centrage
puis un plan d'affaires en bonnet de
forme également là qui venait valider en
fait qui venait donner de la crédibilité
à mon projet et puis ce qu'on me dit en
fait c'est que la terre avait déjà été
vendu le à un homme d'une raison
extérieure
actuellement il y a plus rien qui se
passe sur cette période c'est un peu ça
qui est triste
ceux qui ont acheté la terre d'Adstock
possède des fermes à 130 km de là dans
le centre du Québec ce sont d'importants
producteurs
[Musique]
ces producteurs ont acheté au moins une
autre terre dans la région de Thetford
minds comme celle-ci dans le secteur
Saint-Pierre de bretonne elle était dans
la mire de Marco hupp un producteur
laitier
ça aurait permis d'agrandir pour faire
un peu plus de céréales puis en même
temps il y a pas besoin des terres à
vendre quelqu'un qui ne sauf ben on
essaye de
[Musique]
mais quand il a voulu passer à l'action
monsieur huppé a appris que la terre en
question n'était plus cultivable parce
qu'elle avait été vendue dans le cadre
du mécanisme de déplacement de parcelles
c'est un peu plat pour ça parce que là
les autres
il avance mais au détriment d'une autre
région
selon les documents sur lesquels nous
avons mis la main
docteur 2 on peut être agrandi sur leur
rang 7 et 8 à Saint westslas en échange
de l'achat du terrain à Saint-Pierre de
Breton
le ministère affirme aujourd'hui que ce
genre de transaction ne correspond pas à
l'esprit de la loi initial en fait les
intentions du Gouvernement à l'époque
avait pas avaient pas été nécessairement
le suivi au cours des 20 dernières
années
le gouvernement annonce des mesures pour
corriger le tir depuis le 1er septembre
l'échange de parcelles est limitée à 50
km à la ronde désormais les secteurs les
moins favorisés par l'agriculture comme
la MRC des et chemins ou celle des
Appalaches devraient être moins ciblées
par les producteurs d'autres régions
mais je pense que c'est déjà un grand
pôle vers le changement là mais
insuffisant
l'avenir nous le dira mais déjà de
permettre juste un rayon le X déjà je
pense que c'est une bonne nouvelle
ça serait ça serait assez parce que
la nouvelle loi qui met c'est encore
mieux que rien 50 km mais 50 km à vol
d'oiseau on se rapproche des belles
tailles
c'est un premier pot mais on vient de
mettre un plat un plastage
c'est une table
le réel problème c'est le moratoire
c'est à dire tout est là
[Musique]
Québec a récemment annoncé que le
moratoire pourrait être assoupli
l'intention du gouvernement est de
permettre aux fermes situées dans des
secteurs non pollués d'agrandir leur
superficie sans devoir acheter une terre
ailleurs pour compenser
qui était à 25% dans un bassin versant
dégradé cette municipalité là ce sera
plus tout son territoire qui va être
visible par l'interdiction mais
seulement la portion du territoire qui
est en bassin versant dégradé ce fille
plus à la qualité de l'eau du secteur au
lieu d'y aller là de manière unilatérale
sur sur le territoire donc c'est d'être
un peu plus adapté à la réalité c'est
ça serait déjà une bonne nouvelle ça
serait juste le retour du balancier mais
je pense que aujourd'hui ce qu'on doit
faire c'est s'ajuster ce que je souhaite
finalement si ça serait que notre père
notre père demeure dans nos régions
[Musique]